- [Mark] All right, China.
- Hey.
- [Mark] China, where'd you
grow up, where are you from?
- I'm from Los Angeles,
I grew up in, I guess you can say,
between Highland Park area and
South Central,
80's area on upper Hoover and 5th.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
you had both your parents growing up?
- I didn't have both of
my parents, only my mom
and my granny.
My dad-
both of them were on
drugs, my dad was on drugs,
so he was in and out jail.
So, only my mom was around
and she was also on drugs,
in and out of jail.
She's now deceased now.
So, I only have my dad living right now.
- [Mark] Who was never really around?
- No, not growing up.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And how was your childhood?
- Childhood was pretty rough,
I've been in foster care,
been in some tough situations.
- [Mark] Any abuse or-
- Some abuse, yes.
Not abuse from a parent,
but molested as a kid,
yeah, stuff like that.
- [Mark] And then at what age were you
when you went out on your own?
- Well, I've been on my own
since I've been like 13.
Not so much in the game of prostitution,
but in the game of life.
Because, like I said, my
mom was in and out of jail,
so, she would go to jail
and I would have to cash her
county check, pay the bills,
have one of her friends or tricks
or whoever he was taking me to Civil Brand
to put money on her books.
So, I grew up kind of fast.
- [Mark] Yeah, you had to grow up fast.
- Yes.
Not just fast in the street,
just fast as in mentally
being able to be the mother of the house,
'cause I have two younger sisters.
- [Mark] Oh, you do?
(Mark mumbles)
Did you finish high school?
- I did finish high school.
I went back and got my
high school diploma.
I was a teen parent, so, you know,
I went back as a teen and
got my high school diploma.
- [Mark] Oh, so you had
a child at what age?
- 18.
- [Mark] 18.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] And then prostitution
started for you at what age?
Maybe around 20, 23.
I was grown, it was my choice.
My kids father, we had broken up.
I had lost my job, I didn't
know any other hustle.
I knew people that was in the game,
like my sister, she was faster.
She was younger than me,
so, she taught me the game
and streets of a Figueroa and
learning the game and stuff.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] So, when you started working,
you started working Figueroa?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And did you work
with a pimp or on your own?
- Somewhat not a pimp, maybe my own.
I had protection 'cause
my family is from Hoover
and stuff, so yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, the Hoover
gang is powerful, right?
- Yeah, I had a little
protection, the family and stuff.
And you know, areas and stuff, so yeah.
- [Mark] And then, today your doing what?
- I do a little bit of everything,
I still, if I have, I still turn dates,
I still get clients.
- [Mark] On Fig?
- Not off of Fig.
- [Mark] You look a
little more high end than-
- Once I met Bishop, you know,
he showed me a different way
of working the streets and doing
different things, you know?
Getting money in different ways,
like you said, like casinos,
and on the internet.
Yeah, he totally elevated the game
and showed me how to step my game up.
- [Mark] Yeah, so your more of a high end.
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] Version of what
I also interviewed before.
- Yes.
- [Mark] So you'll go to the
casinos in Las Vegas and-
- Las Vegas, Bicycle Casino,
Commerce Casino out here.
- [Mark] Oh, out here?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] The casinos in LA.
- Mm hm.
- [Mark] And what kind of
money will you make in a night?
- 500, 700, 1,000, depending
on what different clients.
Maybe 2,000, you know, 'cause
I deal with the poker tables
and stuff, you know the high end class
poker tables and stuff,
so, it depends.
A good night, 2,000, a
bad night, maybe 700, 500,
you know?
But, every little bit counts, you know,
you not going to turn down no
money when you in need of it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So, how old is your child now?
- I have a 21 year old daughter,
a 18 year old daughter,
and I have a 2 year old son.
- [Mark] And did you raise all three?
- Yes, still currently raising, yes.
- [Mark] Good for you.
And did you have the dad's help?
- No dad's help, I'm
always did it on my own
with the school for nursing.
The game has always been there
'cause that's how I learned how to eat
when I didn't have anything.
So, you know, street wise, yeah.
- [Mark] And how are your kids,
they're doing fine?
- Oh, yeah.
They're doing good.
- [Mark] Have you ever been arrested?
- Never been arrested for prostitution.
I have people use my name and stuff,
but me, personally, nope,
never been arrested.
Like I said, when I met Bishop,
he changed the game, I didn't have,
you know, all that different stuff.
- [Mark] And do you-
So, working the street is
a very different lifestyle
than what your doing.
- Yes, it totally, totally.
It's more safer, you know.
The streets, you never know.
I've been got in a car
and been raped before
and stuff and all that, like, you know?
That's the reason why I pray to god,
"If you get me out of this one lord,
I won't do it like that no more."
And he answered my prayers,
you know, I met Bishop
and he changed the game, he
showed me a different way
to, you know, present myself,
to dress for these clients.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do your kids know you do this?
- Yes, they do.
But then they don't
because it's so, you know,
but I-
My girls are older, they understand life,
they understand, you know
what I, you know, they
know that you, you know
They work right not,
so, they know that they're
not just going to lay up.
You gonna have to get some kind of money.
- [Mark] Yeah.
If they gonna provide it, going to school,
getting a education, which
that's what they're doing
and also working.
- [Mark] When you were a kid,
did you have dreams of doing
something like nursing?
- Yeah, but honestly I
always kind of thought
about the prostitution life
'cause I had a cousin who
was in the game named Evelyn.
And, as a kid she would come over
with these mink coats and
jewelry and all this stuff.
And you know, it was kind of
influence to a young girl.
So, you know.
- [Mark] How do you think
doing this for a living
has changed you?
- I think it made me a hustler.
You know, and pushed to the limit
'cause you never know, you know?
My story may can help someone
else that's going through it
or been through it and think,
"Wow, I don't got do
it like this no more."
You know?
'Cause I been on Figueroa, I
know how it is, and it's rough.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And you know, jumping in
and out of cars and all that
like, you know.
- [Mark] Do you find when
you were working the street,
like Figueroa, you
would get more depressed
or down on yours-
- Oh, I had used ecstasy,
I had started using
ecstasy and stuff, yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
But I was mentally more stronger
to where I don't have to
use any drugs, you know?
Bishop taught me that too, I
don't have to use anything,
you know?
Be more wise, be more open and you know,
so you can understand the game.
Understand the knowledge that
you getting from the game.
- [Mark] Yeah. So, are
drugs a part of your life?
- No, I don't use any
drugs, just marijuana.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
And your saving money?
- Yeah. It's kind of hard saving money
when every bitch you get,
you know, gotta pay bills,
gotta do stuff.
- [Mark] Yeah, having kids is expensive.
- Definitely, definitely
saving money though.
- [Mark] And were do
you see your life going?
- [China] I've been doing
some modeling and stuff,
I got some gigs and casting agency's
that's been hitting me up.
Target commercials and
different stuff, you know, so.
- [Mark] So you've even
done some modeling too?
- [China] Yeah, I've done some modeling.
- [Mark] What was the
lowest point of your life?
- [China] When my mom passed.
Yeah, that hurt me more than anything.
- [Mark] 'Cause after that
you felt like you were on your own?
- [China] Yeah,
'cause there wasn't
nobody else to depend on,
you know?
She was my backbone.
Yeah.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give a young girl
who's looking to get
into this kind of work?
- [China] Well,
people are going to experience
things on their own,
but I'll tell them that
find their self first before
they just decide to get in
this type of work.
Like, you know, it's a lot
of stuff and people think,
"Oh, all the girls that's
been molested or been abused
are now prostitutes" and stuff.
Well, statistically its true,
but you might could be
the one to change that.
You might could be the one to say,
"Hey, I'mma do it a little different."
I'm not going to use my body
the way everyone else is.
But, at the same time, I'm
not going to abuse my body.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- [China] Oh yes.
(both laugh)
Yeah.
- [Mark] And does this lifestyle
get in the way of that,
you find?
- Oh, definitely.
Definitely.
- [Mark] It's hard for
a guy to deal with that.
- Yeah.
It's hard for a guy to
think that your serious.
Or sometime just another man
just doesn't want another man
that, you know, that
someone else has been in.
But then you find guys that want someone
just because of who they
been with or who they know
or who there, you know, so.
- [Mark] What's the most
you ever made in a night?
- Maybe like 2,000, 2,500.
- You make more money in
the casinos in Las Vegas?
- Yeah.
Casinos, Las Vegas is easy money,
'cause you know everyone's
there, you know.
They just want pleasure.
- [Mark] And how do you do it, you just-
- Not all the time it's
sex and stuff, you know.
- [Mark] You just hang out in the bar and-
- Look cute, stand by the
tables, not too close,
maybe sit down, have a drink
myself, play a game, you know.
'Cause you'd be surprised
what a person'll pay you for,
you know?
I have people that want golden
showers and stuff like that,
you know.
- [Mark] Oh, you get that too?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] Even on a high end
you get have that stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
Fetishes with your toes, just, you know,
want to rub your feet on them, so, yeah.
A lot of times it's not always sex,
it's more of a fetish with me.
- [Mark] It's an
interesting world isn't it?
- Certainly is.
- [Mark] All right China.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- [Mark] Thank you.
That was great.